welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name's hisham azuz
today i'm really excited to be joined by
nicola broomhum who is the proud owner
of brooman recruitment who are a
property specialist recruitment business
that nicola officially started
in jan 2020. nicholas had a
long career in the property sector
before she entered the
world of recruitment and what is clear
from what i can see is that
nikola has a huge passion for servicing
the industry that she spent
over a decade working in nicholas on a
mission
to provide an ethical recruitment
service to the property industry
building real long-term relationships
and giving as much value back
to her industry through things like a
podcast mentoring professionals in the
industry
and even being involved in campaigns
that are focused on driving diversity
within the property sector
and i know how motivated and um big of a
plans
nikola has to make sure brimmingham
recruitment is the property recruiter of
choice so
nicola thank you for joining me on the
podcast thank you for having me that was
quite an introduction
no i'm really excited to unpack your
your journey so far so
first question which we always like to
start on here is in
in your opinion what do you think sort
of what characteristics and traits do
you think make up
a a highly successful recruitment
consultant
okay so i think the
some of the most important traits for a
good uh recruitment consultant
ultimately lie in communication i think
that if you can't learn to listen
and i mean properly listen not just
already be thinking about what you're
going to say next
if you can't do that effectively and
then
transpose that information into a
need and a desire and and a proper
understanding of what somebody wants
you are not going to service whoever it
is that you're speaking to whether it be
a client
or a candidate i think that um far too
often
we don't listen properly to what
somebody is telling us that they want
and we can make assumptions or we can um
i think i think it's it's it's picking
up on
and asking the right questions of that
individual to really drill down
on on what their aims are whether they
be hiring or whether they'd be looking
for a role
so i think that listening piece is key
and then communicating it back
to through your crm through to your
colleagues through to
all of it it's it's that communication
is key
for me yeah i like that so
you've been on a really interesting
journey i think you've been on like a
really sort of
untypical like recruitment business
owner
journey which i was really excited to
get you on so
just to paint a picture for people then
and correct me if i get some of this
wrong but
obviously you worked in the the property
industry right
and it seemed like you worked for a
couple of different brands um
and you was like a it seemed like a sort
of manager or led a team in different
branches um so you was involved in
leading teams that
obviously were letting property in
charge of letting properties selling
properties
um and you did that for yeah over a
decade
like a real long time yeah yeah um and
then
after that it looked like you then sort
of went into
an interesting like consultancy role
where you then i'm assuming draw
drew on like all the experience that
you've got from work for other people
and
getting the best out of your teams
increasing performance to then
do that with other branches and help
them
increase their performance and do those
things right she did that exactly
and then you then went into recruitment
she did that for like yeah three and a
half years and then you went uh joined a
company called crux careers so like
how did where how did that happen like
why why did you then end up going into
recruitment and why didn't you stay like
i know you then recruited into the
property sector but like
how come you didn't then continue
supporting estate agency businesses with
i guess what you had been doing for the
last x number of years
because i had kids so
so i did 10 years in in property 10
years in lettings
um went off and had children um yeah
i had three of them and then during and
so
in between me having three kids i did a
little bit of consultancy and things
like that i dipped my toe in the water
i what isn't on my cv is i even did a
whole stint of child minding i am a
qualified child
so yeah there's all sorts of weird and
wonderful things like
i've kind of i can turn my hand to most
things
um and i set up a proper child minding
business and things like that
isn't on linkedin but yeah it's there um
and
anyway i decided that my youngest was
old enough to
that i wanted to go back to work and
when i tried to get back into working in
property again
and tried to go back to where my skills
really sort of lay
i i couldn't um everybody was saying to
me
you can't work part-time or you can't
work reduced hours
we can't you can't do any of that stuff
you've taken so many years out the
industry despite being a consultant
but you'll need to come back at entry
level and
i spoke to crux who said to me do you
know what nick we're trialling a
self-employed
work from home kind of associate type
model
right do you want to give it a go and so
i did i made my first place i i had to
go and get all my own clients had to go
and get all of my
own candidates very much um uh sort of
you know a lone wolf as a self-employed
recruiter quite often
and um i had no idea where to start i
hadn't had no training
nobody told me how to be a recruiter i
was literally given an email address
and told to go and recruit
so yeah so i'm completely self-taught
but what i did was i went back and
thought about all my experiences of when
i was
in property and when i was hiring and
what what were my
pain points what were my you know when i
when i was a consultant and i was
helping businesses
doing things like recruitment because
staff is always an issue
what to do what to do what were they
telling me and what did i learn from it
and i basically taught myself to be a
recruiter
um
i'd really like to just uh if it's okay
with you just sort of
hone in on sort of nicholas journey
being
a mom growing up family because like
what you experienced in the
property world that definitely
translates into the recruitment world
um it's definitely changing for sure and
probably has changed because of
covid however when we've had women on
this podcast before
what i learned around it and why there
aren't as many
um women in sort of senior leadership
positions in recruitment businesses
was because they approached that
crossroads it seemed like you
appeared to and it was like right so
i've just built 10 years of my career
and i really need to i really want to
have a family
and i'm not i have there's a certain
time scale where it's going to be easier
for me to have children right and you
have to really be aware of that and
understand that
and then it's all of a sudden you have
to it seems like some
industries make you feel like you have
to choose almost like pick and choose is
it going to be in my career that
i sacrifice and then it's all in on
children so i guess
i just want to ask you like what what
kept you going because i guess a big
part of you might have just felt like
really deflated and unmotivated and like
oh my god i've just
spent all this time building this career
now i've sacrificed it all for my
children i'm back to square one you're
getting rejected saying no
even though you've got all this
experience we're not supporting your
part time like what kept you going on
like what where
yeah how was that experience um i did
feel really deflated
in fact um it at that particular time in
my life as well
my husband had just been head-hunted to
um to come and do a new job
we've relocated from the west country to
buckinghamshire where we live now and we
he was he started a new job we put our
house on the market and we sold and
moved in six weeks
oh my god yeah it was it was so fast
um and we moved into our current house
on the 23rd of december
wow with three kids and he
i don't do anything by halves in my life
it seems to me and
he he was already starting his new job
he was working up here staying in
travel lodges monday's friday and i we
moved here my
my kids started the school in the
january um
and at that point i was when i decided
to go back to work
and i had no friends we hadn't we have
no family around us
we were i was in this completely strange
place my husband working long hours in a
brand new job
kids loving school with new friends and
me being completely alone
was probably probably one of the
hardest times in my life and probably
when i was at my lowest
and i actually had this conversation
with somebody the other day and i was
saying that
i'm a doer i you know nothing stops me
i'm i'm
you know i set my sights on something
i'm off i'm going i'm going to achieve
it it doesn't matter what hurdles in the
way i'll do it
and for the first time in my life i
didn't want to get out of bed
i didn't want to do anything couldn't be
bothered to walk the dog
just nothing and i then realized
that i needed to do something and that
doing something was going back to work
and was out because did you feel like
part of that was because you wasn't work
like there was a lot of purpose there
that was
taking them away yeah completely
completely
um i suddenly had no yeah no purpose is
exactly what it was
um and i needed to go back
and it didn't matter who i spoke to
nobody really cared they just all they
saw was a cv with a huge great chunk
missing
and despite you know me owning and
setting up a child mining business and
running that
and and also doing all of this
consulting for
for various other estate agents in that
time as well as dipping my toe in the
water with some
admin support and things like that for
for my husband yeah
you should use like really proactive
line that was showcased yeah
but nobody saw it like that all they saw
was the cv that
where somebody wanted to go back into
doing lettings and hadn't been doing it
for
eight years or whatever it was at that
point um
seven seven years so it was um
it was really horrible it was really
deflating and i was applying for jobs
which i knew i could do standing on my
head and wasn't getting a call wasn't
speaking to anybody and
i felt i felt even worse
um and that's why i didn't feel good
enough
no absolutely not i felt completely
worthless which just added to how i was
already feeling
um but i've you know i've been through
quite a lot of adversity in my younger
years
and i've got a fire in my belly and i
just needed to
almost give myself a big shake and say
nick this is not you
you are not this you are not worthless
which is how i was completely feeling
and then i started to look at you know
do i set up a a crafting business
and and i was trying to think about
other entrepreneurial things to do and
that's when this idea of
trialing recruitment came along i had
nothing to lose
at that point that was the thing yeah
and it was completely reliant it was
completely reliant on you there was no
there was no one to say you can't do
this because of that or whatever it was
it was yeah it was completely reliant on
you which is i guess
which is why you was thinking of ideas
on what you could do off your own back
i guess i have to ask them for people
listening to this that
are thinking i i want to have children
in a couple of years time i'd like to
i'd like to i'm assuming here but again
i
still feel like there'd be a lot of
challenges that um
mums face when it comes back to getting
back into their career
like firstly is like for someone that's
thinking about having children in the
next sort of year or so
what would your advice be to them to
like i guess mentally prepare
or like what would you say to them as to
what to expect
when coming back to their career um
that's a tough one because it depends on
what
what they want to do if so for example
my sister has recently had a baby
and she was back at work within four
months
and yeah because she knew how important
her career was
and she knew her career wasn't going to
wait for her
and she's managed to agree with her
because she's very very good at what she
does she's managed to agree with her
employer
that what she's going to do is work um
part-time hours and work from home
but she's and she's able to do that and
to juggle that
i think that anybody that's thinking
about having children
and is working for an employer that is
going to offer
zero flexibility to them i think they
need to be firstly questioning why
they're working for that employer in the
first place
but also i think there is a very very
strong argument because of covid and
because of what kovid's
done and shown that you don't have to be
in in the office every day of the week
but also you can do quite a lot
um to maintain your career whilst being
a full-time parent as well and what i
mean by that is you can do
regular on constant learning constant
development
you know one of the things that i
probably did wrong is that with lettings
in particular
legislation changes all the time and if
someone's in recruitment for example and
they are
they want to take two or three years out
to have a child before that child goes
to nursery or whatever
make sure that you're still keeping your
finger on the pulse of the industry and
what's happening
it doesn't mean that you've got to go go
to work or perhaps
do a little bit of volunteering or
keeping in touch days those sorts of
things
keep that keep that connection there i
i very quickly just sort of walked away
and washed my hands of it
and that was my downfall very much so
yeah
yeah no i think that's great advice and
i know i know it is very intrinsic isn't
it it's very like is you have to be
aware of like
yeah how important your career is and
like what yeah what you're willing to do
but i think that that's great advice is
don't just check out um like yeah keep
keep understanding what is what is
current in your world and
you can obviously the great thing now in
today's world is there's there's loads
of
channels and ways that you can do that
and and then i guess
what comes up for me just thinking about
what you said is then also
i guess like really trying to over
communicate to your employer on
so i feel like again i'm assuming here i
think
the conversation that i've had in the
past with women when i was in
recruitment
or just in general for people that think
about having a family i think sometimes
they can try and people can try and be
like strategic of when they tell them or
and and stuff like that and i feel like
like trying not almost like hide it or
like i don't know i feel like
if you're in a company where you want to
find out are they going to support me is
there going to be flexibility i feel
like you're better off trying to
understand what that looks like before
you're then in the position of having
children and then expecting it then you
don't
i don't know yeah did you agree with
that i agree we actually we actually
have a client at the moment
who is recruiting because their their
their manager in their team
has said to them that they would like to
have children in the next couple of
years
so what she's actually done is she's
approached her boss and said i want to
have a family in the next couple of
years
so count but i don't want this team to
dissolve
while i'm away for 9 12 18 months or
however long she just chooses to have
off
so actually can we think about planning
ahead and future succession
and make sure that we've got the right
people in that can look after that team
when i'm not here for a few months
yeah and i'm not everyone's going to
react like that but i think that's great
yeah you're going to feel way better
about it when you then have that time
when you do then when you are raising
your child aren't you because it's
it's been it's been collaborative rather
than like oh
i didn't i don't know yeah okay that's
that's interesting
the other thing as well though is that i
think that i know quite a few people
that where the the woman is the
breadwinner
and she's gone back to work very quickly
and they're that the dads are the ones
that are taking that that leave
the dads are very much sharing it i i
personally think we could do
very well to learn a lot from sort of
scandinavian countries and the way they
do things
um i think it does need to change but
that's probably a conversation for
another day
no i love that and i'm glad we were we
went there because i think that's this
is
sort of um we don't talk enough about it
on this podcast for sure
um so obviously then ended up in an
environment then where you it was
completely reliant on nicola
to support yourself um and what i just
love about this is like obviously
you're self-aware enough to be like
right what challenges did i face when
i was hiring and stuff like that but
obviously you use
i guess the advantage that you had is
that you really went into like this
whole
recruitment naive really
and just like so i guess so so it
looks like obviously did it for just
over a year so let's just touch on that
really quickly and then we'll go into
you then transition to starting your own
recruitment business but like what
what was that sort of first year of like
yeah
building up candidates getting clients
like what was that like
um it i loved it i absolutely
love business development business
development for me is like
in my element doing that so
i i just you've just got to be ballsy
when you when you're doing something and
and it's something that i don't struggle
with
um luckily but i think very quickly
i just learned like i said i pulled on
all my old resources
in terms of what i felt and what i'd
learned and all of that sort of stuff
and and i just went out there and
attacked it
um made my first placements within two
weeks
um i yeah i just or very quickly
established that linkedin was my friend
um and the more i worked linked in and
the more connections i had and the more
i became real on there because that's
the other thing is that i think
i have quite a good um identity on
linkedin
um and yeah brand and i think
that i learned that quite quickly um and
then
i i was i was working part-time juggling
three kids picking them up from school
trying to
multitask cooking tea whilst on the
phone to clients and candidates at
you know half five six seven eight
o'clock at night
with whilst bathing three children
because my husband
has is an md of an estate agent so
he he works long hours too and i just
became this
expert at multitasking
absolute expert at multitasking my kids
became experts at youtube unfortunately
[Laughter]
i i just it was mad and i was
uh probably the top performer even
though i was part-time and working from
home
and everything i was doing i was doing
my own way
um there was no sort of rule book there
was all i had to do was kind of send my
figures in once a week of what i had
what i'd done how many interviews i've
booked how many you know
how many things have come in all of that
sort of stuff my kpis if you like
um and other than that i was completely
left to my own devices which
for me worked really well yeah yeah yeah
i love that so so then obviously
then there was a period of so then when
did you i feel like because you started
in that context in that environment
the thought of you then doing this on
your own it just makes sense doesn't it
i feel like
like like surely you would have thought
about that after you've done it a little
while
did like those i thought start coming
quite
quite quickly around having your own
recruitment it did
they did come quite quickly um but i
think
i think i was because i went into
recruitment games you know if i'm crap
at this it really doesn't matter
um and because i realized quite quickly
actually i wasn't crap at it i was i was
actually right at it
um oh yeah i did start to have those
thoughts very early on of
why am i doing this why am i paying a
huge chunk of my commission
somebody else when that could all be
going in my pocket definitely went
through my head it went through my head
almost on a weekly basis
um and then like those feelings that i
had when i was looking for a job again
started to come in that little niggles
of self-doubt
actually nick what is it is it that
other their brand that they want or is
it you
you know what is it and i don't know i
think again
i wasn't sure i wanted to risk it for
quite a while and then
it got to the summer and i think i was
having a conversation with
with my best friend who also actually
works in she does internal recruitment
and she was like nick why are you still
doing this just go out and do it on your
own and i was like
anyway i seem to have a bit of a blip
where i i really wanted to spend some
time focusing
on my kids and and i didn't want to be
focusing too much on recruitment
and it just meant that actually my
placements were dropped
dropped off yeah and it was naturally it
then
seems like it was a good time for me to
go well i'm not walking away from shed
loads of commission
yeah so let's give it a go and
i left in the i left in the august and i
set up in my kitchen
in the september i probably actually
realistically left about
i don't know end of may beginning of
june in my head i've mentally checked
out knowing that that was going to
happen
and then set up in my kitchen yeah so
we're that's what we're gonna really
uncover but because you've mentioned it
i'm doing a um an event
next week which is all about overcoming
imposter syndrome
so let's just talk about those feelings
i think i saw you share something around
this on linkedin at some point like
i'd love to speak to people about this
like i don't know i guess what a lot of
people want to know
it seems like that you recognize that
you was having self-doubt
and you are self-aware enough to sort of
maybe
find out what the reasons for some of
those feelings are
but i guess people want to know like
what
what did you then draw on that helped
you snap out of that or
i don't know things that helped you go
well no actually i do have a right to do
this or i am
someone that can do this i don't know
when i sort of
say that to you and ask does anything
that have helped
because i'm sure these things feelings
still come up now right because
i'm sure for you there continues to be
like a lot of firsts right
now i've found that right so there's a
lot of firsts and you're just like this
like am i just winging this whole thing
like what and also you've
i am i haven't got to the point where
i've got employees i'm
still relying on freelancers and stuff
like that so for you you've now got
employees and you've got people's
livelihoods that you're supporting so i
guess
yeah things that helped you make you go
no you know what nick i am i am the
person to be doing this and i am
right i should rightfully be doing this
what comes up for you
it it actually goes back to something as
i referred to earlier adversity
of when i was younger i have massive
imposter syndrome
huge in fact on a daily basis i go
i kind of question so much of what i'm
doing
um and actually it's probably my team
around me in particular jake
kind of like almost gives me a
metaphorical slap around the face and
it's like suck yourself out
come on but the reason why is because um
when i was a when i was teenager my
parents just give you a very quick
summary yeah
i was teenager my parents split up i
stayed living with my dad
my dad got together with the most vile
woman
in the world um she was horrible the
first time we met her she turned around
and said to me uh look mate your dad
doesn't like cats
i've got a cat i don't like kids your
dad's got kids
oh wow she was horrible absolutely
horrible yeah and so
she actually suffered from bipolar and
uh
made my teenage life hell um
she threw me out at 17 and at 17 i kind
of i'm still in the middle of doing my a
levels
dropped out of my level was actually
only finished with one as level because
i kind of had to go to work
and at that point i
kind of reached a
i was at a point in my life where i kind
of felt sorry for myself and
could have gone down the poor little me
route or i could do the
screw you i'm gonna i've got this
i've got this i'm gonna forget you i'm
gonna move on with my life and i'm gonna
be something i'm going to be
somebody and actually interestingly the
whole reason i became an estate agent is
because i needed a car
and it was the only job i could get
which would give me a car
um so so yeah i had i had a bit of a
challenging t
few teenage years and every time now i i
question myself or i doubt what i'm
capable of i pull myself back to when i
was that 17 year old
like literally with pretty much nowhere
to go had to move in my boyfriend at the
time who i hated
didn't want to be because i had no other
option
and and yeah it's every time now i
pull myself back to that point and go
well you got through that and you
managed to make something of yourself
you haven't got any
haven't got a degree haven't got a
levels have complete university of life
experience
and look what you've done nick look
where you've gone yeah yeah do this
you can do this and that's what i kind
of try and
get back into that yeah yeah and i guess
so i guess
it can yeah that's interesting i guess
at that point in your life
obviously especially that when you're
that age there's so much wrapped up in
like
what you're doing if you're going down
an academic path what you're achieving
there does it uh
so i guess there would have been a lot
of feelings of like
wow i haven't even yeah all of my
friends or peers or whatever have got
these
levels so that's why they can do that
whereas you
there's not nothing yeah at that point
it's like well
yeah yeah i was a grade a student
i absolutely grade a student so all of
my gcses all a stars and a's
um i will yeah so that makes even worse
then doesn't it because
you yeah that's a lot i've got one a yes
i'm a failure and so why would someone
hire me or why would someone give me a
chance yeah no i'm
no not at all because i i knew i was had
i knew i had the ability to learn i knew
i had that intelligence you know i was
on track to do
economics a-levels and all sorts of of
pretty heavy stuff um and i knew i had
that
behind me and i knew i could do it um
but i'm also a big sister
i've got a little sister and a little
brother and i needed to
show that i could do this and and i
still feel like that now even now i'm
still
you still take that sort of matriarch of
the family type
thing yeah yeah yeah so started
so what what was like in your head
obviously we're
really like obviously before we started
this so we started in your kitchen but
then as you shared with me and we'll go
into it like
it really started like jam 2020
right yeah so i guess so i guess you was
feeling like yeah why would i not do
this for myself i've got some success
let's give it
was you also thinking like what's the
worst that can happen still then like
what
like i'm not going to be in the worst
position if i give this a real go or
uh yeah i mean i'm very i have to admit
you know i'm very fortunate like i
touched on my husband's got a very good
job uh we weren't financially reliant on
on me doing well necessarily um
yes we needed the income but i could
have probably got
done something differently or something
else if it had all failed
but i think i was confident enough that
because
like i said earlier because i was this
lone wolf working at home
on my own anyway when i was working for
the other brand
um it didn't really feel any different i
was just an email address
everyone just knew me as nicola brumam
so it didn't really matter
there wasn't a huge shift what i didn't
do is i didn't take a single client with
me i didn't take any data with me i
cleared absolutely everything off
as of course you're supposed to do and
and i very much went into it on day one
with a brand new notepad going right
here we go again so um
yeah i love that but very quickly people
came
back to me i didn't go after anybody
everybody came to me and everyone said
look whoa
where have you gone i've got you got
this other somebody else has emailed me
where are you yeah yeah so so when
when did you start thinking about so
obviously you then were just smashing it
out like a lone wolf like as you have
been
like what i guess the first thing like
what um
what did you did you then have did you
then think about this in a bit more of a
strategic way because you'd been doing
that
for over 12 months before like what was
did you have a plan or was it just like
right let's just
like did you decide you're gonna focus
anywhere like or was it just like let's
just get money in the back let's just do
deals
yeah it was literally let's just do
deals no no planning no strategy
no nothing i just i just thought right
let's just see what happens and see
where it goes
if i'm honest i kind of thought it would
be something i wouldn't
necessarily do really full time almost i
kind of thought it would still work
around the kids and and things
and i think i got to about
the end of october and i
had i was literally on the phone and
every time i was on the phone
my phone was ringing three or four times
to have three or four voicemails to
phone back
and i was it was relentless absolutely
relentless and the market was crazy busy
and i i re i realized
very quickly that this couldn't just be
a part-time thing this was actually
going to be
a big deal and um i went and spoke
i've had a men i i contacted some
companies and said look
i've never set up a business before
properly like like this
i mean you know i've done like i said
the child mind you bit but it's totally
different industry
help what do i do recruitment
recruitment businesses
yeah you know i think i need an
accountant do i need an accountant do i
need to put it up as a limited business
what what do i need to do um because i'd
always done it as
as just a sort of self you know
self-employed thing
um and i went and met with a guy who's
still my mentor now
um how do you approach that a lot a lot
of people want a mentor or
feel like they could benefit from one
like was it did you just put your cars
on the tables like look this is where
i'm at
this is what i'd really love help with
did you like i don't know like was it
did you say like
hopefully i can help you in some way or
like i don't know how did you
try and share it like ask in a way that
maybe they could feel like something in
there for them as well or did you or
didn't you
uh well i i went to social media so i
went to linkedin and i went to facebook
and i spoke to friends
i actually went and met with three
business coaches
and and i said look this is me this is
what's happened
what would you what can you do for me in
the next 12 months to help me because
obviously i was going to pay for
that business coach advice and i came
away from two of them going
yeah they're all right and i phoned my
husband and he'd be like oh you don't
sound particularly full of beans and
i was like no they're okay i can't kind
of work with them and then i went and
met mark who's my current business coach
and i remember getting in the car and i
phoned porn away right i could do
that and just talked at him with so much
excitement and energy because
he's he's a mentor and an accountancy
firm in one
so it means that it's all under one
umbrella so for me i was like right tick
tick tick
but also he's just he's like a a male
version of me
with both yeah really if you do disc
assessments we're both really high eyes
um on a disc so we're in your face
bubbly chatty
all of that stuff so we just bounce off
each other
um and actually he helped me and said to
me
nick first thing you've got to do is
read the e-myth um
that's a great book fantastic book um
and it really shaped my business from
now
now it has really really shaped my
business and
he said go and read the e-myth and then
come back to me and tell me what we're
going to do to set up your business and
you need to come up with a name
and we need to get you as a limited
business asap
and that was the december and then at
the beginning of january 6th of january
room and recruitment was born hmm
i love that i just absolutely love your
willingness just to take action and take
the first step
um i i think it's amazing so let's talk
about this i know where
we're sort of you're going into your
second year in business now right
yeah um so wait so that means jan 2020
obviously march 2020 covered hit them
right
yeah so i just just realized okay wow
okay
so like did you then what just talk to
us a bit about because i think this is
what people like so
you've had all that experience obviously
you've got this relationship now
did you then start to like what what had
you like what did you then have a plan
like or like did you then
how did you how did you think you was
going to be different because i feel
like up until that point
you was really reliant and i couldn't i
feel like anyone listens can really see
why would i not work with nicola like i
feel like she'd really do a good job
like i'm sure people really bought into
you and then you and then you delivered
so like how how was you thinking about
this now recruitment business where it's
bigger than you
and we're thinking of employees thinking
about things that are doing things that
aren't just reliant on you
like what was the thought process then
to try and be different because i'm sure
he was aware how competitive it was
uh yeah very aware of how competitive
it is um there's lots of people that
work in this industry um
all i wanted to ever do and
is be real and that's probably the i
mean
our our words that when i set up bremen
are human
effective and reliable and that's what i
want your values
there are values and that first value of
human is where i saw our biggest
change um i knew how i had been treated
when i was looking for a job i knew the
people i spoke to i felt like
i was just a tick box sometimes ticking
the box of
have you called her yeah i've called her
yeah not got anything for her yeah
and i really wanted to provide a service
to the property industry of
ultimately someone that gave a [ __ ]
that's that's where i saw how we would
be different now how
did i have a business plan no
did i have um an idea of where i wanted
the business to get to at that point
when i started it
no and in fact i actually started with a
self-employed model myself
really yeah so will
is was my first employee who still works
for me now um
and will came on initially as a complete
trainee
to do my admin um i was sinking was it
employed
or was it yeah he was he was employed um
will
will um had been working at tesco's he
was a grad he'd done a business degree
and as soon as i spoke to will on the
phone i loved him i was just like
brilliant really really like this guy's
getting in for an interview
met him knew straight away that he would
be like a little duracell bunny
which he still is um and what was the
sell on that quick because i think
sometimes people
who have smaller who are early on that
recruitment business journey can
sometimes be
what's the words um they can think about
how that person may think about their
business and if it's not the biggest
business in the world and it's just one
person or it's growing so they can be
aware of that
like what was the what was the sell to
will obviously i'm sure he bought into
you but what
did you say this is where we're going
this is where we are i don't know
what was the i myself to him is was that
i just told him my story i told him what
i'd done before i told him how much the
business had gone through the roof since
september
which was ultimately why i was hiring
him um and i told him that
what i wanted is i wanted somebody that
was excited about the idea
of a startup i actually wanted somebody
that went
oh there's an opportunity here i'm
joining it at real grassroots not even
grassroots level but
like further down than that real
seedling
of a business i want to join that and be
part of that and be part of that growth
i didn't want somebody who was cautious
of that i wanted someone who saw it as
an exciting
new prospect not a negative thing
so that i didn't i didn't want to have
to sell it and if i did have to sell it
for me that meant they weren't right
right
yeah that's fair enough so
when we say i know i i love this by the
way and i i
and i think what you've done a really
great job on is like really stayed true
to who you are
like now and also online and i think
clearly like you said you recognize that
quite early i think if anyone wants to
connect with you on linkedin and start
seeing your content and stuff like
we can all get a real clear picture of
who you are and the things that you care
about and
that that's who you are so i guess how
does like
being human then translate into like
commercials if you get what i mean so
what what i'm saying is like
so i want to just do the right thing be
a good human
care about people like how do we then
how does that then help your business
are we is that our sort of pitch to
people as to why this should work of us
i don't know like how does that then
translate into you growing this
recruitment business and it being
well received by people so um
during co when covert hit and um
we paid back pretty much every rebate
that we've done
um well it hit in the middle of march
and
so many of our placements that we've
made then in the january into february
were still during
in their rebate period and they all got
sacked
wow so almost every single bit of money
that we made
at all in the whole of that first
quarter was wiped out and in fact i
think
we're in a negative um by the time i
take them to will's that
will salary etcetera are taken on an
office all of that stuff
um and i was convinced that that was it
brewman recruitment was no more when
covid hit
um and i was like right it's done fine
we'll just
kind of pack it all away and we'll start
again when we can
and and then i i again gave myself a bit
of talking to him i was like no
that's not what you're gonna do so
during kobe what i did was i
just went out and did every single
possible thing i could that was really
positive
so if you were if you and i were
connected on
linkedin on facebook at that time you
probably would have seen me dressed up
as somebody from um
anchorman the film and every day
i was joined with four or five other
property industry
suppliers and and people and we would
just read good news stories
so rather than trying everything to be
about negativity of covid
we'd go and we'd talk about i don't know
a whale that had given birth in you know
blah blah blah
or whatever it may have been or we'd
talk about all this like captain tom was
a big one
and yeah every single thing we tried to
do was try to put a real positive on
stuff
and people loved that people needed that
and then i very very
quickly established that actually the
industry as a whole needs this
and working in the property industry
there's a real lack of women there's a
huge lack of diversity
there's a mental health issue that no
one talks
about um and and i felt that
because of that presence on on social
media and because of all that good news
stuff and
and and actually i quite like having i
quite like being vocal
i quite like having a voice i like being
controversial i like standing up for
for things that i care about and that
other people care about as well
i decided that what i would do is i
would be that recruiter
that would champion things that other
recruiters were perhaps a bit
wary of because you know the the estate
agency old boys club might not like it
if i start causing waves
and i very quickly became known and i
think i
hope i really hope i'm known within our
industry
as the recruiter that you can trust
that's got you back that will listen to
you regardless of what your situation is
that will help
you that will try to be positive and put
a spin on things
will fight your corner for you and so
we what we what that did was that meant
that from a candidate perspective
we could be relied upon and all of the
guys that work for me can all be relied
upon because we have those same values
and those same beliefs
and and actually we are a little bit
different but also from a client side as
well
those clients were also seeing those
same things and those same traits and
um i i got interviews and
one of the things somebody said to ask
me about is that as a business we have a
no [ __ ] policy
and what what that means is is that if a
candidate is an [ __ ]
see ya we're not dealing with you don't
be rude to my team off you go
but also if a client is an [ __ ] as
well
bye bye i'm sorry we're not willing to
work with you we're not here to just be
a supplier
we're here to partner with you enough
companies out there that yeah see you as
a partner yeah
and because i was interviewed on a um
industry publication about this and was
was quite vocal about it almost
overnight
our a lot of our clients suddenly
stepped back in line
you know yeah invoices paid on time
every time
um they knew that if they were they
didn't behave if you like
i'd call them out um we had a couple of
clients who said to me oh um
can we can we uh maybe not maybe not
sort of like you know that
late 20 30 year old women i'd probably
prefer someone either younger or older
why well the chance that they're
probably going to have kids so i don't
really employ them right okay
go off and find another recruiter
because i'm not recruiting for you
bye-bye
and and because i would go to linkedin
and say look have this today
off you go if you are a company that has
these types of policies
don't come to me all of a sudden people
got scared
and it didn't mean that they got scared
as in they don't want to use us
it just meant that they suddenly thought
oh god we've got a recruiter in the
property industry that's actually being
true and real and and honest and
and that and my some of my values are
actually like that so what it's done is
it's meant that we attract clients
that have the same values as us most of
the time i love that
and which is great so i love that you
did that um during coverage so like when
did
if you remember i'm sure it's a bit of a
blur now so like i'll see march and then
like you did all of that so you stay in
front of mind you're trying to be
positive
i think that's when that human value
really got tested right and
clearly you showed up you was human and
like when when did business start
picking up again then like was it long
before people were going nick
we're starting to see things move now i
want to speak to you i've loved
seeing you start like when did things
start to pick up
well we offered we offered out our
services to
um when i say we will was furloughed
because well was employed
jake was self-employed at that
particular moment in time
so um he and i worked together and we
what we did is we offered our services
to everybody and anybody regardless of
industry to help with their cv
we just said look if you want somebody
to help you to give tweak it
give you some advice whatever it may be
call us email us we'd do it for you
completely free of charge off you go
just again try to be that really helpful
person
um and there is a company that in our
industry
that came to me and said i absolutely
love what you guys are doing
we're recruiting for 10 work from home
roles
and because of how you've kind of acted
and the way you've been and how ethical
you are which is really in line with
what we do
we'd like you guys to exclusively
recruit for 10 roles
and this was in the june and
it was probably our savior at that time
um both financially and kind of
i suppose emotionally to a certain
extent and jake that's a long time isn't
it march april may
doing a lot of in i'm sure you're in
your head like this is good karma
i'm not doing it because of just that
but it will come back people will help
things will start turning and
that's one of those moments right it's
like wow people have seen what we're
doing and
that gives you even more motivation then
doesn't it i think it was may i think it
was may because
and the reason why i say it was may is
because
we suddenly the housing market came back
very quickly
um and the housing market came back i
think at the beginning of
middle of may time it came back and
estate agents were allowed to go back to
work
and almost instantly all of those people
that were still hiring back in march and
february that had probably laid off all
the people we'd placed was straight back
on the phone saying
we're busy we need more people again and
our
we got busy overnight and at that point
i recruited johan who and
jake was put onto a permanent contract
of an employee we don't do self-employed
anymore
yeah and actually ironically he and i
had had a conversation about putting him
on point
about the 14th of march
so sin so how is it how is it so like if
we were to
how would you describe the last like six
months then obviously you've
you've um hired more people like what
how was it
like in hindsight what what have been
some of the the biggest learnings then
during that period and
over the last sort of first 12 months
for you
um cash flow i i didn't monitor and
didn't look at my cash flow
it's it's something that used to give me
sleepless nights
and and i just sit there panicking
knowing what was in the bank account or
what was
coming out of the bank account and uh
putting in a cash flow forecast and
things like that
really helped me um to understand things
better i'm
i'm very um i can be very flippant with
with
money generally i can
i think as well i i'm very reluctant to
say no
to things um i've got
i get quite a lot of fomo i miss i you
know i don't want to miss out on stuff
um and i i
i can i can sometimes
be too quick to try and do too much
as well um so for example when i set up
the brewman podcast i probably wasn't
ready to set the room and podcast up at
that point
and you know we've got this we did new
branding we've got a new website that's
being designed at the moment we had new
podcasts we had new offices we had new
employees
all in the se at exactly the same time
um and i know the saying of you know if
you want something done ask a busy
person and that probably is me
but i was running around like a nutter
um and actually yeah but too much i just
taken on
too much and there's only so many plates
that you can spin at once and
i think for me i learned that i need to
slow down sometimes
you know i can be an absolute bully in a
china shop with things and
i have my heart set on something and
i'll just decide that's what i want to
do and i can be very tunnel visioned
with things
but that's why i've also got the
employees that i have
and by that i mean for example jake
raynor who works for me is very
sensible in terms of money
he's very good with money he's very good
with um he's very dominant person
he's he's he's a leader he knows the end
goal
whereas i've got other jake jake holt
that works for me who's like this little
voice on my shoulder every time i go
a bit crazy that's like rein it in nick
just
calm just calm down right let's sit down
let's think about this let's talk about
this let's put it rational
and and because i've tried to employ
people that are the complete opposite of
me
and have very different traits to me
rather than surrounding myself with
people like me
it's given a real feeling of balance
i love that and that was a real
conscious thing that you did
yeah yeah i love that
so how did you end your first year in
business then what did you end up doing
revenue wise
uh 205 grand
and how you feeling about this year do
you think it's gonna what's the goal is
it
double that more no this year we should
do
six or six fifty so
it's gone mad it's gone absolutely mad
um so
it's yeah last last year was a bit pants
but yeah
hey ho we were in and out of lockdowns
yeah
um and how are you so like obviously i
just feel like you've been through so
much to get to this point and i feel
like
i feel like there's obviously there's
still plenty of ground to do and i'm
sure there's
a long list of things that you can
improve but i feel like you've got a
sort of um
solid foundation now at least and like
how are you feeling about the future of
this recruitment business that's been
really organic and
yeah like how are you feeling about the
future of it i'm i'm really excited
about the future of it in fact i i took
a phone call yesterday from somebody who
said oh nick you know
i'm not ready to join you yet because
i've got a couple of bits and pieces i
need to sort out but actually can we
have a conversation towards the end of
the year because i've watched your
growth i've seen what you guys do and
see what you stand for i want to be part
of it
and i've made the hiring mistakes in the
last
six months that's probably one of my
biggest actually learning points is i've
made mistakes i've hired the wrong
people
um which is a recruiter it's probably
not something you should admit
um but i think i'm really looking
forward to what the next few years hold
i don't want us to grow too quickly
i don't want us to grow too fast
in terms of hiring again the wrong
people i need to make sure i've got
the right people in this business
because um
we are you know we're a people people
industry in the people business
and i i love my team and i love my guys
fiercely and will do anything for them
and they know that
um and uh yeah i'm looking forward to
what what the next
next well the rest of this year holds
actually
i'm looking forward to what on i'd i'd
be silly not to ask because
it's a real common thing that people
hear on the podcast around the hiring of
your own business thing i guess
what what are the things that you are
now sort of non-negotiable for you i
guess when you're
hiring for your business that maybe you
didn't do before
um i we've established our fit
we hadn't properly actually sat down and
established whilst whilst i said i
wanted to hire different people and
i still stick i'm a big believer in
diversity
what we we've established things like
all of us have been through a challenge
at some point
or all of us have pushed ourselves at
some point we are all
um there are certain characteristics and
certain traits in all of us
that make us who we are and um
i think we've now learned what those
what those are and i was unfortunately
trying to hire somebody who was just
chatty bubbly and
and kind of good on the phone but being
a being a recruiter is so much more to
that and a big big one for us
is emotional intelligence and i don't
think i think
we need to make sure that that is really
high in recruitment and i think that's
probably where i went
wrong yeah fair enough so look before we
finish
just a couple of sort of more like quick
quick fire questions
um obviously you've been part of the
recruitment industry now
for a couple of years what
what what would you love to see improve
about the recruitment industry
because i'm sure you've come to learn
the the perception the industry has and
like you're yeah you're now going to be
a real hopefully a real um
real part of the recruitment industry as
well as the property industry right so i
don't know what how do you think we can
change or improve the industry what
would you like to see improved
i'd like to see a reduction in kpis
um i'm not a big kpi fan and i feel that
um
a lot of the time big companies that are
constantly monitoring calls
monitoring number of interviews cv sent
i don't think that makes for good
recruitment
i think recruitment needs to be um
better better
quality not more quantity and um
unfortunately i've spoken to several
people that have worked for large
companies large
recruitment firms that have just had
kpis being bashed over the head
all the time and have now fallen out of
love with what
what this industry is really all about
so that's bigger do you hear that a lot
i think that
i think the language around it needs to
change i think
um so i always like asking this question
so to be fair i was going to ask you
like what book have you read that's had
the biggest impact on you but
would you say as to the emys then really
yeah yeah it's such a good book um
what you can maybe go to the estate
agent days on this but i think it's a
fun question to ask recruiters
because of all the stories that you hear
but what what did you spend your first
biggest commission paycheck on
a holiday actually yeah a holiday
um yes yes when we were allowed to go
yeah yeah i'm hoping we could do one
soon oh yeah i paid it on a very very
very nice holiday that we've been
wanting to do for a long time nice so
the final question i always ask
people i know you sort of mentioned this
but like what what's the ultimate goal
for your recruitment career now do you
think i want to be the go-to property
recruiter
in the uk um because we cover all of the
uk
i want to be that go-to one
um we've been we're involved in quite a
lot of industry events and bits and
pieces over the next um
next few months and i would really like
that
that name and that brand of brewman to
be synonymous with property recruitment
um i think it's time that there was a
change and a shift in in this
particular part of the industry and i
want us to be at the forefront of that
change and be recognized as being
different for the right reasons
yeah no i think i have no doubt you'll
achieve that and i think
you're well on your way so yeah thank
you so much for
for sharing and being honest and thanks
a lot for coming on on the podcast
thank you for having me